let's do a mental math test is the
number 613 thousand two hundred and
sixty one divisible by 11
have you figured it out hi this is
pressure Locker in this video I'll teach
you a math trick where you can test
divisibility by 11 in your head here's
the trick starting from the first digit
on the left you want to subtract and add
every other digit in the number the
first digit is 6 so we will subtract the
next digit of 1 add the next digit 3
subtract the next digit 2 then add 6 and
finally subtract 1 this is an easy
calculation to perform and we get the
answer of 11 if the result from this
alternating sum is divisible by 11 then
the original number is as well so 11 is
divisible by 11
so we know the original number is
divisible by 11
let's use this trick to do a couple of
examples
let's do fifteen thousand two hundred
and thirty seven in our heads we
calculate the alternating sum is two two
is not divisible by 11 so we know the
original number is not divisible by 11
let's do one one two two three three
four four
we could take the alternating sum but we
can easily see every other digit cancels
out the digit before so we know zero is
the result
zero is divisible by 11 so the original
number is also divisible by 11 it's a
really cool trick you can figure out
whether a number is divisible by 11 by
performing a simple calculation in your
head and you don't have to actually do
the division and the reason the trick
works is thanks for watching please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math
you can get my books there's a link in
the video description catch me on my
blog mind your decisions which you can
follow on Facebook and Google+ you can
also follow me at pressure Locker on
Twitter Instagram and Tumblr and you can
support me on patreon